this is the un's first major achievement
in yemen
in years the houthis and the government
have agreed to
exchange prisoners the deal was
initially struck in 2018 in sweden
but never implemented the 1081
individuals
would and indeed will represent
the largest release operation during the
history
of the conflict in yemen peaceful
negotiations can succeed
and they will succeed in bringing relief
to the yemeni people
and building confidence for the peace
process
if implemented this new deal would pave
the way to a broader
prisoner swap six years
since the houthis took over the capital
sana fighting
claiming the lives of thousands of
people
the fate of thousands of prisoners is
yet to be decided
the un hopes the warring factions will
resume
talks soon to free all prisoners
at the end of the day only parties to
the conflict
can bring long-lasting positive change
that yeah many people so need
i believe over the last days we have
been reminded here
again that small steps that can have big
impact are possible and much needed
in yemen today in the past
tribal leaders and clerics brokered
major
prisoner exchanges but never managed to
get all the parties to end the conflict
the saudi-backed government insists a
political deal will only happen
once the houthis pull out from the areas
they controlled
in 2014 and had over their weapons
a condition dismissed by the iran-backed
rebels
who described themselves as legitimate
representatives
of the yemeni people in 2018
uin envoy announced what he described as
a landmark deal in yemen
the stockholm agreement consisted of a
prisoner swap the creation of a
demilitarized zone in cities on the red
sea
an end to the fighting in tires and a
commitment from all the parties
to start political talks to end the
conflict
but within days the deer collapsed and
fighting resumed
but many things have changed since the
stockholm agreement
the houthis have consolidated their
military gains
in the north uae-backed secessionists
controlled most of the south president
hadi has lost significant
influence he runs the few areas still
under his control from exile in saudi
arabia
the u.n has described the humanitarian
crisis in yemen
as the worst in the world most of its
people
including 12 million children need
humanitarian assistance
many hope this agreement may be a step
towards an
end to a war that is raising the threat
of yemen's disintegration hashimoto
al-jazeera